[Music]
my name is psy I'm a product manager
with Google cloud and with that let's
let's get into it so I think hopefully
most of folks in the room are security
or security adjacent have some
experience with the problems of
protecting users you know users are
under attack from phishing malware and
fraud at all times and its really unique
compared to protecting our own employees
because we have less control over the
environments in which our users exist
but they're just as important to our
business you know with phishing you know
ninety one percent of alternate attacks
start with phishing that's one huge
vector and not only to your own systems
but to your customers and your users and
8% of revenue for many online businesses
is lost to fraud every year the problem
is just the defense of these systems
especially when you go all the way out
to the users computers requires a lot of
data and the ability to protect at the
client level in an environment that you
don't control now just for some
background you know here at Google we've
been protecting our own systems with two
spectacular platforms so for the last
decade and maybe even more in some cases
the first two Safe Browsing which
defends over three billion devices from
phishing and malware and then the other
is recapture which defends more than two
million websites from fraudulently using
bots and we really took these two
platforms and leverage them to create
offerings that you all can now use in
order to protect your own platforms
users and devices the first of these
products is reCAPTCHA enterprise and
reCAPTCHA enterprise essentially an
extension of reCAPTCHA v3 into the
enterprise space that will allow for
more nuanced and granular control and
smarter and more refined decision-making
around what to do with fraud that you
observe on your site the second two are
based off the safe browsing the first
one there will be phishing protection
which essentially leverages the power
safe browsing to discover phishing sites
that are targeting your company to add
those help you get those added to Safe
Browsing as well as enable you to
potentially submit your own URLs you
observe to be attacking your users to
Safe Browsing and then the third
protocol introduced is web risk and web
rift is a URL again built on the power
of Safe Browsing that enables you to
check
in your own infrastructure on your own
site in the content that you serve for
unsafe URLs and with that we'll do a
little bit of a deep dive in each one of
these here we'll start out here with
reCAPTCHA enterprise and really wanted
to kind of frame the problem of kind of
how we see a lot of people think of
recaptures just defending against bots
which it does but it also defends
against all different manner of attacks
and this could be you know scraping
fraudulent transactions account
takeovers synthetic accounts false post
money laundering and many many more I'm
never never cease to be amazed by the
creativity and innovation of our
adversaries so they're just this myriad
of threats that try and abuse your sites
and really the goal with the reCAPTCHA
and recapture enterprise specifically is
to make it as hard as possible for these
adversaries to access anything on your
site be it a login page or even your
home page and make it as easy as
possible and in fact as frictionless as
possible
for your own users to engage with and
conduct legitimate business on your site
now how are we able to do that you know
recapture really has an unprecedented
level of visibility of abuse across the
web from the two million sites that we
work with and were able to kind of
combine all these collective
collaborative defenses to create a
unique view on what is what legitimate
and what illegitimate transactions look
like across this large population which
enables us to train machine learning
models they're able to recognize attacks
in their many and evolving forms and
speaking of evolving I wanted to walk
you through a quick history of or
captures to bring up to speed because I
think people's understanding of this
platform very because it's just been
around for so long and has been
experienced by so many of different
people in different ways you know really
got started with the kind of squiggly
bit of text that you're trying to read
and type in and you know as BOTS got
better
you know our defenses had to evolve and
that's why you see kind of these click
boxes and crosswalks where the
challenges are become a little bit more
complex and I know many people in the
audience probably myself and myself
included can't touch the mic have
struggles solving and the reason they've
gotten so complicated is not only just
because of the AI threat but also
because of the farmer threat so there
are large groups of even warehouses full
of people who are solving these
challenges so the threat is in fact a
human threat as well as a bot threat and
we
we have to distinguish legitimate from
fraudulent transactions not just BOTS
from humans anymore
not to mention that AI get smarter every
day and maybe those will converge with
the human threat and so really that
brought us to this which you know is
nothing just kidding so really what it
is is a piece of JavaScript that can
live almost anywhere on your site
anywhere on the web
interact with the user and give you
essentially a risk or a confidence score
and whether this interaction is
fraudulent or not without interrupting
your user and without being easily
tested or defeated by a piece of AI or a
bot written by an adversary and really
this is our effort to go into the
behavioral analytics base and really try
and use not just the challenge but in
fact everything you can observe about
the user from their interaction on the
client in order to make a determination
again that's not only better for users
and that it causes the zero user
friction in fact most users aren't even
aware that they are passing this test
but it also is much harder to defeat
because the adversaries don't have a
strong idea of what they have to program
against or a way to train their own
attacks and now with the reCAPTCHA
Enterprise you know what we found is
that with the introduction of v3 you can
put the snippet anywhere which means
that you have a much broader set of use
cases around where you can use this I
think in v2 a lot of the common use
cases we saw was around the login flow
when there's already going to be a user
interaction and already an interrupt
there we can add a little bit of extra
friction keep it secure now with a
frictionless experience you can put it
anywhere on your site kind of just like
Google Analytics would and because of
that there's many more use cases we want
to enable enterprises you all to attune
your business to an ax tune your fraud
and risk teams too and so we added you
know higher granularity risk score so
rather than four scores you get ten
reason codes we'll tell you why we
thought something on your site was high
risk or something that might be worth
looking at and then an annotation API
which is a means by which you can help
us tune our model and tune our
protection to your particular site and
your particularly use case we get higher
accuracy and higher granularity on our
defenses for your own site and your own
business so just with a higher granular
you score kind of one example at one way
to think about it is if you have very
little granularity you can do defense is
a very different use case
for example defending a login page
versus defending a home page if you
defend a home page
maybe you allow some questionable
transactions through or maybe you don't
care at all if you don't care bots
scrape your site many you know retailers
we work with that's the case whereas
very few people want anyone scraping or
having automated uses of their login
pages that's generally a bad thing now
that would be good to have this come to
four buckets and that was that what that
was designed for with higher granularity
with these ten buckets you can draw even
finer controls for example the way you
treat threats against a password reset
form versus a login form maybe those two
are different vectors in different
levels of security and you can start
making these really fine-tune controls
and tuning that you know true positive
false positive false negative rate for
every specific part of your business you
can ensure that you maximize the
friction again for those attackers and
you minimize it for your users or
legitimate folks trying to use your site
along that same lines we have our reason
codes and here are just kind of a few
and again kind of going back to maybe
the scraping example with automation if
we identify something as an automation
attack maybe it doesn't matter if it's
on your home page maybe you don't care
if folks are scraping you know the basic
information is like the whole world to
know but rarely would you want to see
that on a login page or potentially like
a sending message page or various other
avenues for abuse within your site and
then the other two patterns are just
ways for you to potentially identify
different behaviors that you wouldn't
want to see on your site so for example
the unexpected environment indicates
that they're captured snippet has been
extracted and that's a common way that
these were CAPTCHA farmers will extract
the recaptured snippet into a different
environment and have it solved
externally typically not a good thing
not being uses isn't used as intended as
well as the unexpected usage patterns
which could be any wide variety of
things where you say hey this doesn't
match the typical legitimate behavior we
see for users on your site on this page
so again we make it really really hard
where the adversaries to defeat this are
starting to have to map to not only
typical users not only to your site but
specifically to the behavior that would
be expected on your site on your page
which makes it a much much tougher
defense and also much easier on your
users and then the last piece here is
the annotation or the annotate API call
so when you use recap
it'll send you back a score on a label
so again kind of that score there's ten
scores as well as the labels that we
showed before as well as and then when
you receive those you can annotate them
and send them back to further help train
this model something we heard
continuously is that you know we really
would like to share ground truth of
Google and really help use the ground
truth it you see in your business to
help us create a model that's
particularly tailored to your business
into your company and this will enable
us to do that and here's kinda just how
it works it looks quite simple but
basically you just take the assessment
that you're giving back from Google as
you think about implementing this be
sure to save that number it's like your
kind of receipt and then use that to
send us back a note that says well this
was a legitimate or fraudulent
transaction and you can do both and you
can do for whether we're right or
whether we're wrong all will help us
train and label our data sets to get
better a tune to your specific site so
rather than again being served by this
general model the entire web we can
start using using all of our protections
and knowledge to tailor a model specific
to your site and just a little bit for
folks who may already be v3 users
actually can't see but how many people
in items are v3 users already
that's pretty guys see four or five
hands go up by this is the product team
in the front row all the heads snapped
around of intense interest so the folks
who are on VC or any version of
reCAPTCHA really would the only change
you have to make is let's say this thing
does have a laser point does it anyways
at the top of screen here you can see
you know the end-user client and the
reCAPTCHA endpoint will kind of have a
little conversation a toke will be
generated and sent back to the reCAPTCHA
customer server from the recaptured
customer server which is kind of where
typically your server code will live
typically you'd send that to the
reCAPTCHA assessment call to be decoded
instead you'll send it to a GCP
reCAPTCHA enterprise endpoint it's it's
basically like one line of code change
and essentially it'll work in more or
less the same way except you just get
more data back so just a note if you're
transitioning from v3 to reCAPTCHA it's
about a one line of code change should
be very very straightforward and we
designed it to work in a very similar
way to v3 so to make that transition
seamless and also here's kind of what
the assessment will look like when you
get it back again you can see you know
the confidence highlighted there is
going to be point one so that's kind of
the score we discussed it runs from zero
- 1 in decimal increments and then you
also get reasons if they exist it could
be blank but if not we'll give you the
reasons for example automation that you
might expect and so I know it's early in
the morning so and I know it's dark
nathie or so if anyone's dozed off now
is the time to wake up well do we'll do
a little live demo which is always the
most exciting thing to do as a presenter
especially of a security product by the
way so let's all do this together do me
a favor go to G KO / reCAPTCHA slash
demo and I'll leave that up for a couple
more seconds and if we can can we switch
over to the to my laptop there you go
and hopefully you all will see a screen
that looks a little bit like this now
this is just kind of a test demo page of
what a user experience could look like
with a CAPTCHA and what the admin
experience looks like let me say please
do not put in a real password username
here this is just a test so we don't
want any actual data and all you put in
whatever you want and login and you'll
see the same ignore this let's see a
little thank-you screen I know chrome
wants to save your password where'd the
lies use password managers they're great
except in demos so if you see here you
know kind of standard frictionless user
experience you wouldn't even know you're
using reCAPTCHA and by the way if you're
curious on your devices you can go to
this page and sign up right now so we
had a little sign-up link but as an
admin here you can actually see that
actually a lot of people - that's great
so thanks for the early engagement looks
like about 18 hours so people tried to
assess this page and everyone got
through a lot of legitimate traffic no
bots in the audience as far as I can
tell which is good however I try and run
it with a bot and again the team here
helped me out to write a headless
browser that will go and attack the page
much like you know many of the bots that
attack your pages in the wild will and
then a little return a screenshot of
what it sees and will see that it has a
you know hopefully if it runs here we're
always on the Wi-Fi which is like a it's
never a sure thing but it'll basically
run and then hopefully when the output
is finished it will show a screenshot of
what it sees there we go and you can see
here it's seeing a 2fa challenge rather
than the Thank You page that you all saw
and you can imagine in your
sites and your own businesses that you'd
want essentially those users have that
frictionless experience that you all saw
and have BOTS like this that are running
these repeated automated attacks seeing
it to a face screen so they can't really
test passwords against your page and as
we go back to the analytics you can see
as an admin these attacks happening you
can see that they're marked as
illegitimate transactions and you can
see that the reason code is automation
so you can start to track these attacks
as they happen and then again start to
tune and plan your defenses around that
so and let's switch back to the slides
that's the end of the demo so thank you
all for participating in the morning
it's good to see that enthusiasm for
great security products and so that's
about it you know really our goal with
reCAPTCHA Enterprise is to stop fraud
not users you can learn more at
cloud.google.com slash recapture
Enterprise I will note for those of you
I can see typing this in already this
will all go alive at 9 a.m. tomorrow
morning so all this stuff is technically
pre-launch and getting the sneak peek
was it about 22 hours before everyone
else does so take a note and then it'll
be live in in about a day the next
product we wanted to dive a little bit
deeper into was phishing protection and
you know just to outline this you know
the way I like to think about phishing
and something our team has worked for
more than a decade on is it doesn't
matter what kind of big huge scary cast
you build if you leave the gate open
everyone's gonna come in and that really
is the case with phishing we build some
pretty amazing defenses we see everyone
across the industry build amazing
defenses I think everyone in the room
probably knows that phishing is still
your number one problem it's people
leaving the door locked
really the goal with phishing protection
is to stop people from clicking on
phishing period right we know that with
enough tries essentially the tries are
free people will always be fooled into
clicking at some level so really we
really want to ensure that as few people
see those links as possible and
especially for those links that are
targeting your brand's so for example
something that might you say the Google
logo or the Gmail logo or things that
are huge and our iconographer page
didn't note their login pages offerings
to fool users especially using say
mobile devices and phishing protection
leverages the power Safe Browsing to not
only classify those pages but also to
add them to the safe browsing list when
they match our policy in order to ensure
that users will see a big red warning
that looks you know a little bit like
this color before they ever go to a
phishing and Malware page so they're
very aware and typically they don't go
there I think our click-through rate is
well below three percent so in the few
places in our business where you focus
on having the lowest click-through rate
possible just to walk through a little
bit of how this works you know you as a
business can submit URLs to phishing
production so oftentimes there's
existing detections from referral links
from your own email and security tools
or just from your own scraping of the
web usually there's some really smart IT
person someone has written a cool bot to
find things that look like your brand on
the web you can submit those to Safe
Browsing for crawling so we can confirm
that they are truly indeed malicious we
have a team of about 60 engineers who
spent the better part of a decade
building machine learning to recognize
these things and recognize them as they
of all so we have incredibly good
detections around those we also in just
data from a variety of third-party
sources or even first-party sources from
Wendy and Google once there's all those
are all added to Safe Browsing well
notify you as a customer so you can in
suit your own countermeasures be it
takedowns blocks notifications user
education whatever it is you've found
work well for your customers in your
business you'll get that protection on
three billion plus devices I'll note
this is far beyond the reach of Chrome
or any Google products the vast majority
of browsers security companies you know
web filtering companies use this list in
order to protect their users so get a
wide variety protections almost wherever
your users are and then finally this
will be integrated into the GCP
reporting analytics through cloud
security command center quick note just
write a technical level this is what
submitting your looks like it's very
simple you you know use your project
number and API key to submit a URI and
you know then we take it in and you'll
see it come out the other end in cloud
security command center and if we can
switch over to my laptop will show the
quick demo what that looks like from the
cloud security command center vantage
point here's kind of the dashboard
you'll see as an admin of cloud security
command center which is kind of your one
single pane of glass to see all the
different security activities within
your business you know it's a great way
GCP were trying to consolidate all the
many - birds - no we all love to flip
through doing our daily business you can
see here the finding some summary you
can see there's about 177 findings and
when you click on that you'll see a full
list of the different findings that are
available as you click in you can see
kind of full details will offer so you
can see kind of the data was discovered
you can see you know at the bottom there
if on source properties was it flight by
Safe Browsing did it was it reported by
the organization or essentially was
reported to us and what was the URL and
oftentimes folks will look for that
combination of flag by Safe Browsing and
reported by you because obviously the
ones you care most about are the ones
you found you want remediated and you
want to know what we did about it so
we'll provide that and we'll also be
providing kind of support from the
product team you have escalations or
questions around why something was
classified we can offer that back I know
for some folks Safe Browsing and our
fishing products have been a little bit
of a black box so we're hoping to enjoy
a little tighter partnership with our
enterprise customers through this
product all right and that was it so
we'll switch back to the slides last
time I promise thank you to the guys in
the booth and here you can just learn
more here at cloud google.com slash
phishing protection and it's a way to
help you finally prevent phishing before
users click and the last product we'll
talk about today is web risk and web
risk is essentially you know a way to
protect you from malicious URLs you know
we all know the URLs can contain
dangerous stuff you know phishing
malware all sorts of bad stuff and Safe
Browsing examines more than a billion
URLs every day in order to create a list
of a million you're a million or more
URLs and really it's access to that list
that we're providing down you know and
here's an example maybe how it can work
in practice so let's say there's a you
know there's a web site acme tech
reviews for you know tech events in San
Francisco like you know Google cloud
next and it gets more popular but as it
gets more popular you see how much this
malware come up and this is actually a
very common Trinity behavior we see as
sites as businesses hit this inflection
point where they attract users are
becoming really popular we see the fraud
come right along with it so it rides
right on the coattails of your success
which is often quite frustrating and
then it kind of dampens it so as that
second
popular attracts more malicious content
that's showing up on the site it starts
to drive users away which is bad for
that business and bad for that business
is growth and so really with the web
brisk API what this business you know
Acme tech reviews could do is send good
and bad URL is kind of all URLs posted
to its site to the Weber scape here to
check to see if they're known to be
malicious are known to be unsafe or not
with a web risk API will send the data
on known unsafe or known bad URLs back
to the Acme tech review site and then
Acme tech reviews can only post the URLs
that were not found to be bad to the
actual public site and that way kind of
makes sure its content is a lot safer
and more secure and then its users
aren't being targeted by the propagation
of malicious content and here's really
quickly what the queries will look like
there's two basic methods one is you can
essentially submit a URL that's the one
on your left and sending submitted you
all get a verdict back pretty simple the
other one essentially consists of a
local database of partial hashes you can
run queries against and when there's a
query match will send back and you can
see that on the right you can see a list
of different URLs that may match this is
not only faster but it's also
privacy-preserving because google never
actually sees you all you're looking for
we only see a set of possible URLs you
might be looking for you might be
interested in as you know here expire
time will kind of denote the time for
which we would like we are terms
encourage you to consider the URLs
unsafe and the negative expired time is
the time which we discourage you from
making another call because it's
unlikely vertical will change even if
there is no verdict so kind of consider
it like you know don't ask again for a
little bit and we go back to our example
so now let's say Acme reviews is install
this and starting to filter their sites
what'll happen is they'll start to make
sure that their site is free of
malicious content and you know the users
return and their growth can continue so
for any company that does kind of
content filtering has large amounts of
user-generated content you know highly
encourage them to take a look at this
web risk API we actually launched this
back at RSA so this is the one product
that's up you can go look at it now at
cloud.google.com slash web risk and
again yeah we have date on more than a
million URLs from scanning billions a
day
and I wanted to kind of just close
quickly here with a discussion of you
know how this fits together is a
hijacking prevention use case so fraud
and just attacks in general things that
are self propagating work together you
know someone fishes a user steals a
password tries it on a website through
automated credential stuff or even
manual credential stuffing and then it's
that compromised site is used to repost
more fishing and more malware and that
you know negative malicious cycle
continues
we really designed this suite to work
together to block every step of that
cycle so phishing protections designed
to stop users from clicking on phishing
to ensure that they or the passwords
aren't stole in the first place we ever
capture enterprise and among many other
things we'll stop credential stuffing
and stop those passions and being used
even if they are compromised or very
least giving you some notice that people
are using these in an attack and then
finally we have web risk which prevents
the propagation of phishing and malware
through these large user content sites
and through any sort of security
filtering systems via email or anything
else to ensure that even if a site is
compromised it doesn't start spreading
to the rest of our ecosystem
[Music]